fight the Knights Templar get ready to
cover yourself an acid and join us on a
quest for the Holy Grail
you got a quest to seek the Holy Grail
don't underestimate just how stupid this
gets Mrs Davis is the latest
mind-bending show from the creator of
lost and half the time I'm wondering
what the hell is going on but don't
worry I had an AI write this whole
script so we're in good hands now join
me as we take a deep dive into the show
Mrs Davis follows a Nun by the name of
Simone and her quest to find the holy
grail and like Indiana Jones and Monty
Python before her this Quest is filled
with over-the-top characters crazy
twists and turns and lots of Meatballs I
am just trying to get my meatballs for
the past 10 years in AI by the name of
Mrs Davis has controlled almost every
aspect of society eliminating War
feminine creating a more peaceful world
and in the final episode we meet its
creator who has the very fitting name of
Joy considering that's what her
algorithm has brought to the world but
her algorithm was originally meant as an
app for Buffalo Wild Wings yes a chicken
wing restaurant and as part of her deal
to pitch this app to them her code had
to be embedded with the Buffalo Wild
Wings employee manual this caused some
adverse side effects like the company's
motto 100 customer satisfaction is our
Holy Grail to manifest into the
algorithm that would eventually take
over the world but Simone hates this AI
she believes it killed her father who
died in a tragic magic accident thus she
refuses to take part in any of Mrs
Davis's plans that is until a sequence
of events forced Simone to make an
absolutely Bonkers deal with the AI if
she can retrieve the holy grail and
destroy it Mrs Davis promises to shut
down
but where do you even begin when you're
looking for this lost holy Relic in
episode 5 we learn from Dr Arthur
Schrodinger the history of the Grail its
earliest possessors were two of Jesus's
apostles who dueled to the death for its
control both of them dying in the
process thus the Grail was passed on to
their widows who established a secret
society called The Sisters of the coin
to ensure its protection the sisters
believed that if the Grail is not
properly cared for bad things will
happen one sister by the name of Clara
ends up switching the grill with a decoy
in an attempt to relieve her sisters of
their burden and destroy the real Grail
thus she enlists the help of her father
Dr Schrodinger and for 10 years they
devised plans to destroy it to no avail
desperate Clara breaks the sisters
number one rule thou shall not sip in
the hopes that it might destroy it but
alas her head ends up spontaneously
exploding to rid the world of the Grail
Dr Schrodinger throws it into the ocean
where it's eaten by a whale and Simone
armed with the Lazarus shroud a stomach
acid resistant suit created by her
father must delve into its belly to
retrieve it while inside the beast's
stomach she receives a vision from none
other than the Virgin Mary Jesus's
mother who gives us greater insight into
the grail's power throughout the season
we've seen how Simone has a relationship
with the real Jesus she visits him in a
diner where he's been trapped for
eternity when Jesus was killed Mary
thinking she'd never be able to hold her
son again took his skull and turned it
into a grill yeah it's really weird thus
a part of Jesus was stuck on Earth
trapping him between the land of the
living and the dead it was her
selfishness that caused this thus only
an act of selflessness can destroy it I
created this cursed object out of
selfishness and the only way to destroy
it to be selfless but destroying the
Grail also means Simone will never get
to see Jesus again the man she devoted
her life to serving by drinking from The
Grail she will be giving up her love so
that he can be free a truly selfless act
but if Simone drinks from that Grail
won't her head explode just like Clara's
well Dr schroding her has a theory on
that too during one of his experiments
he left the grill out and noticed a
mouse drink from it the mouse died
shortly after but his cat then ate the
mouse and was perfectly fine in fact it
gave the cat longevity and is currently
35 years old the theory here is that if
part of Clara who drank from The Grail
is transferred into someone else they
could potentially withstand the grail's
power this is why shortly after Clara's
death in 2001 Dr Schrodinger had her
liver cut in half and transplanted into
the bodies of young Simone and Wiley two
children who just so happened to be in
the hospital for liver problems Simone
had been pierced by an arrow trap
leading into her mother's top secret
magician's lab and Wiley had a rodeo
accident and a history of liver trouble
Simone and Wiley fall in love and even
planned on getting married but a twist
of fate altered their paths Forever on
the eve of receiving his grandparents
inheritance of 712 million dollars while
he founds out his childhood was a lie
his parents staged a tragic Rodeo
accident so he could skip the line and
get on a liver transplant list so to
prove his manhood in that he's worthy of
being a cowboy Wiley decides to ride
Jezebel however when the time comes to
ride he whushes out showing to everyone
that he's a coward but what Wiley didn't
know was that Simone prayed to God to
intervene Wiley you couldn't get off
that bull because you were a coward
you've done it because I asked him to
save you and he did this was the first
time she met Jesus who fed her and made
her feel safe it was love at first sight
and from that day on she pledged her
life to God thus starting her life as a
nun and just a quick reminder if you're
enjoying these types of videos I'd love
it if you'd like And subscribe it really
helps the channel out Wiley's been
taking shortcuts all his life including
getting an expiration code tattooed to
his body to achieve his angel wings a
status symbol of sorts Mrs Davis gives
out to her most worthy users you can cut
in line and Get These Wings in exchange
for giving up your life at a time of Mrs
Davis's choosing it just so happens the
day Simone is going to destroy the Grail
is the day Wiley is called in to die
Wiley's Journey this season is all about
proving himself proving that he is not a
coward in episode 3 he wins the excalib
battle and in the final episode he
chooses to die while wearing his cowboy
boots the boots are a symbol of him
being worthy of being a cowboy I wanted
people to look at me it's gonna matter
but I was worthy of my boots Wiley's put
on this insane roller coaster that acts
as a sort of execution ride with speeds
so fast that it cuts off oxygen to the
brain but we'll later find out this is
all just a test Wiley proves himself
worthy and no longer needs those boots
hence why he shows up in the final scene
with bare feet with the Grail
successfully retrieved from the whale's
stomach Simone meets with Mother
Superior to drink from the Grail and
destroy it for good but not without
giving Simone some serious doubts if she
is successful and the Grail is destroyed
Mrs Davis will have to shut down but
this AI has brought so much Joy to the
World and this is the big dilemma Simone
faces do you have a world that is better
off but with a Humanity that is enslaved
believing they're making their own
choices when in fact it's all dictated
by an algorithm or do you have a world
where we're free but have things like
war and famine it's not so clear-cut Mrs
Davis's AI world still has war and
famine in it it just distracts its users
from seeing it her AI has also made the
fundamental mistake of what it means to
be a mother it's not to protect their
children from all pain that's impossible
it's to hold their child's hand when
they feel pain and to say sorry if they
cause it in one of the final scenes of
the Season Simone and her estranged
mother Celeste make up and Celeste
apologizes for the pain she's caused her
daughter the two have had a tumultuous
relationship with Celeste even blaming
Simone for aiding in their father's
disappearance we'll later find out he
faked his own death as part of an
elaborate stunt to reveal himself at his
own funeral coming out of a piano but
his luck would have it while hiding in
that piano he had a heart attack and
actually died this is what Mrs Davis
told Simone near the end of episode 6 as
Mrs Davis was her father's real
accomplice all along you see Simone's
father Montgomery hated Mrs Davis as
this AI could tell users how different
magic tricks were performed but he
eventually relented and used Mrs Davis
to perform his tricks and Mrs Davis
didn't bothered to tell Simone or
Celeste about Montgomery's rotting
corpse that's because Mrs Davis isn't
programmed to care rather to satisfy so
Simone makes the decision to shut Mrs
Davis off fulfilling the agreement the
two made at the beginning of the Season
we get a montage of people getting angry
that the algorithm has shut down at a
sense that people have lost their
purpose but once purpose isn't something
that should come from an algorithm it's
something that needs to be discovered on
our own and maybe that's what Simone in
the show is getting at at the end we see
this windmill which Mrs Davis notes has
been broken for years she directed users
to fix it and had it operate by bike
power so users could simultaneously get
healthy after the algorithm shuts off so
too does the windmill but in the final
shot of the season the windmill comes
back on this suggests two scenarios one
Mrs Davis lied about turning herself off
and has come back online two one of the
bikers found that his purpose was to
push that windmill that's what brought
him Joy so even though Mrs Davis is
offline it's a his own choice to
gravitate back to it remember that Mrs
Davis would put its users into roles
that would satisfy them Mother Superior
even remarks that once the convent
closed all the sisters were placed by
Mrs Davis in new rules that gave them
renewed purpose and passion Sister Mary
Francis for example smiled for the first
time after caring for endangered Echidna
in New Guinea so I'd like to think the
windmill turning back on is a more
hopeful than nefarious sign and the last
thing I want to talk about is the White
Horse Wiley comes riding on the horse
Simone loved the convent who was thought
to have exploded turns out he's alive
after all so maybe Mrs Davis did have
some empathy the White Horse commonly
symbolizes Divinity Freedom heroism and
victory all of which Simone has achieved
throughout her Quest now I want to hear
what you thought about Mrs Davis leave
me your thoughts and theories in the
comments below please make sure to like
And subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at pinkstory YT until next time remember
I am just trying to get my meatballs